yeah today we are in Louisiana at the
ponies on a delta Pony play event these
events are very competitive just like a
regular horse show event we end up with
some crashes and wrecks people go down
over two jumps the competition gets
pretty crazy sometimes all of our
outfits that we make are based off of
bio horse equipment or made out of bio
horse equipment that's been rearranged
to fit humans and can get very costly
people are very proud of their outfits
they put together I'm pretty sure he was
abused as a young Colt meet Joe a war
horse named after Spielberg's greatest
movie he's just like a real horse except
that he's a human and not a horse at all
he's a leader in the Pony play community
which is one of those alternative
alternative lifestyles where adults
dressed like horses and participate in
barrel racing dressage and sodomy I'm
calling freaks but to be fair everyone
who likes horses kind of seems like they
want a bang one I know they're majestic
Pony play is legal bestiality and if you
have ever found a banca kushnir
attractive you might be into it it's not
to be confused with bronies who jerk off
to children's cartoon horses long stuff
wouldn't take a run at Pinkie Pie
horses are as they're known at Quiznos
pastrami are something both wealthy
people and Kentuckians love it's a lot
like racism but Joey is just a normal
dude who puts his shoes on one nail at a
time that's why I asked him to join me
at the famed Tosh Baffert stables where
only 21 horses have died which is still
less than Santa Anita in this week's
ce-web-rity profile
[Applause]
my newest thoroughbred is here
I've been dining about this one boss
then lose 20 pounds you back here you go
here you go go
easy boy easy boy easy boy here yeah
there you go yeah Joey War Horse it is
an honor to be in the same stable as you
glad to be here that's a real nice coat
you got there
you mind how often do I need to brush
you Oh daily okay about how long do you
do it don't tell them clean tell me the
origin story of Joey warhorse
well I represent a male horse uh-huh
Joey in case anyone doesn't know comes
from the movie war horse which is where
I took the movie from how long ago did
you start dressing up like a horse
I started in 2012 I just decided I
wanted to put on some of the gear and
found out hey it kind of turned me on
turned you on sexually or just enjoyed
it well both are you turned on right now
no I'm not when I put my horse kieran
you go into what you call ponies face
uh-huh I've done this to her
I was actually hooked to a cart and
impotent gear for 14 hours straight
let's seems like a hate crime actually I
enjoyed it I mean I think that's what
you have to look at with a lot of hate
crimes and as does the person enjoy it
where are my manners can I offer you a
Salt Lick
sure good there you go how is she
salty how many people are there just say
in the continental US there's probably
three or 400 okay so it's enormous
there's there's an event here in LA that
goes on every year in August on these
conventions is it sexual
do people get aroused putting their
stuff on yeah some do but that's not
what the events all about not saying
that don't happen and at night and
evenings so when the Sun Goes Down the
Pony boners come out yeah that's good
you get your Johnson out if you needed
to
quick enough to use the bathroom or or
whatever needs to happen that was a good
answer you know the drill
oh sure q there you go you know mo are
you into male horses or female horses
may I ask female okay do you have
children no I'm not even married no you
ever been married no lucky man yep I
tell you what my marriage is the worst
decision I've ever made
I see you have a tail how's that
attached butt plug no that is done but I
don't care for no but plugs what about
the bite deep admit the bit did you know
it's champing at the bit
not chomping at the bit no it's chomping
at the bit no no the expression is
champing at the bit
no it's chomping at the bit no no no
you're wrong everyone thinks it's
chomping at the bit but the expression
is champing at the bit no it's actually
talking at the bit yeah
champing at the bit now choppy you're
not gonna give me this are you nope is
chomping at the bit you chop on a bit
that makes sense but it's champing at
the bit
no I don't mean to embarrass you but it
looks like you yourself
oh yeah that's fine don't worry about it
is part of the gig gotta go you gotta go
yeah not just an owner how many hands
tall are you probably right around four
and four hands I don't really understand
that increment of measurement could you
tell me what it is
sure even when you measure someone's
hand sideways it's about four inches so
you're only four hands tall
that's only this tall yeah no I got that
wrong oh wow I don't got a brain fart we
do go just do the math if it's four
inches three hands is a foot yes sir
then you're eighteen hands tall at six
feet I don't screw that up real good
my horses are right at five hands no I'm
sorry damn it no okay I got it
no it's it's it's 14 14 and a half hands
I knew a guy who's to work here that
used to drink horse semen that's it he
mix it with iced tea some weird Oh
horrible yeah that's weird what's one
thing we would be surprised to learn
about you well then I'm basically a
normal everyday person other than when I
do by Pony play are there any bodies
buried in your backyard
oh no we'll see that's surprising how
many of your friends have you had to put
down because they twisted an ankle
luckily none we didn't have to set no
water to the glue factory yet they don't
make glue from horses anymore do they
no did they ever supposedly that that's
been the word yeah it's supposedly it's
supposedly okay okay
champing at the bit now supposedly
supposedly I'll give you chomping at the
bit I won't
all right enough chitchat I think you're
ready for the greatest two minutes in
sports the Kentucky Derby closed Ace
Hardware let's get you cleaned up
Oh
my God look at this magnificent steed Oh
your first customer hop on up
we're two up with a quarter in order you
think you put it in
oh you maniac the saddlebag
pretty sure this breed of horse isn't
allowed within 500 feet of a child I'm
not gonna waste a quarter I respect that
what's that one movie where the rich old
man wakes up with a horse head in his
bed okay
you